it's no easy thing to get to ebo a
distant island that was pounded by
cyclone Kenneth the aid agencies are
struggling to reach it by air so we took
a boat and spotted it after seven hours
at sea we can see the devastation from
here thousands of trees stripped of
their branches or toppled over by the
storm
it looks gray and lifeless nothing was
spared when the storm circled ebo no
home or building here was left untouched
[Music]
the district hospital has been abandoned
for the structure is soaking wet
bandages and equipment have been
discarded in the wings
we found the director amid the wreckage
the roofs damaged the food's wit the
medicines are wet we can't take anything
away nothing residents appeared from
behind the ruins which they've used to
protect themselves from the elements
sticks and metal sheeting have been
fashioned into tents Ancha cares for a
family of nine come and see I live like
an animal just go and see did you build
this after the storm yes I did this so I
could keep my things my clothes dry we
don't have anywhere else to sleep this
is the kids we found the Mozambique and
President being deployed as a door but
his administration hasn't done much on
ebo no one we spoke to has received any
help at the islands airstrip a large
group of people were waiting for food in
fact they'd been waiting since 5:00 in
the morning
I'm Lanier we're struggling here our
food is wet our house is destroyed
the beds are soaking we're living like
that just struggling people hungry yes
truly speaking yes
a helicopter with aid had managed to
land but local officials control the
distribution process it's slow and it's
bureaucratic despite all the help on
offer the islands church wasn't spared
for the tiles were ripped from its roof
but the cyclone hasn't challenged the
congregations faith they and their
fellow residents will try to endure John
sparks Sky News ebo Island